Alright guys, so here is an example number one for the holy grail model
Notice that I didn't show you the examples from the high time frames, but I'm going to use the high time frame combination here
So from monthly we're going to go to the daily time frame and from daily
We're going to go to one hour time frame to look for our entries
like similarly you can go from daily to one hour to
Five minute and from weekly you can go from from weekly to four hour to 15 minutes
And for daily as I said before from daily to hourly to five minute and from four hour to 15 minute to one minute
I wouldn't say one minute. Just go with two minutes. That is
Actually reliable than one minute. So what do we have? We have taken out the external liquidity right on the monthly on gbpsd
We have this fairly gap in the discount, right? Sorry in the premium here. So that is going to be our drawn liquidity
So price takes out this let's go to the daily time frame and see what happens
So price takes out the liquidity here now
We want to look for a market structure shift on the daily time frame
And we have the market structure shift on the daily time from here. Look at this fractal high here
We have a candle to the left, right?
Which is shorter than this this candle and then we have the candle to the right which is also shorter than this high
So that is our fractal high price breaks that structure right giving us a market structure shift now looking back here
where is the
PD area in the discount
This fair valley gap right here, right? There's no clean auto block nothing just this fair valley gap
So we mark out the fair valley gap and remember when you are on the higher time frames like four hour daily weekly and monthly
You want to use the 0.5 level off the fib energy
Sorry off this gap of this fairly gap, right?
You don't want to be looking for confirmation entries when price taps into it straight away
Just wait for price to come into 0.5 level. Okay, so
drawing the fib for on the fbg you can see we have
This is the 0.5 level. Let me delete the fib
Damn right there. So
Let's go here. So now once price is into our PD area. We want to mark out the range high, which is this, right?
So we're going to mark out this here and this is from where we're going to scout out the one hour market maker model
Right. We want to look for a market maker model starting from this move down
Right because this is the last move
When before price went to this PD area, right? So we want to look for a
one hour market maker model, right?
So price is into the 0.5 level here at the moment
Before that we want to identify the consolidation phases. So right away where you can see is you have this consolidation phase right there
Then we have the accumulation phase two
So basically the first consolidation is called consolidation
The second consolidation is called accumulation one and the third
consolidation is called
Accumulation number two right accumulation could just be a pullback right and
It would be considered a consolidation
But for the first consolidation you have to look for a decent size or decent consolidation something like that, right?
It doesn't have to be like a big consolidation just
Train your eyes to just identify consolidation. This is a clean consolidation
You can see we have these highs here then we have this lows here right here, right?
So price is like going nowhere. We went up down up. That's it. And then we have push up
Push down, right? We have accumulation down accumulation down
Into our PD area, right?
So now what we want to do is we want to look for a shift in the market structure on the one hour time frame
Remember we're going from monthly to daily to one hour. So right here
What do we have? We have a shift in market structure and we have this clean auto block
Remember bearish candles continuous bearish candles. So now from here, we're going to go long right there
We're going to put our stop right below the slope and we are going to target
The consolidation high which is right here
Giving us 10.7 something rich to reward
So most importantly our entry is during London three right at three. So let's see how this plays out
So it consolidates for a bit
We
Have a continuation purge here
Right, but our target is fixed and right there we have our take profit hit for 110. So let me teach you something else
Use your Fibonacci from this range high
to this range low
So every single PD array after market structure shift is going to be respected every single auto block below the 0.5 level
Once price is above the 0.5 level the chances decrease, right?
So you want to get in before price goes above 0.5 level and
I mean i'm not saying that price goes above the 0.5 level then comes back and you cannot take the trade
Yes, it is possible when price goes above 0.5 level and then comes back into discount. You can look for entries
But you cannot buy above the 0.5 level. That's what i'm saying
so
Over here
You can see we have hit the take profit. We had this breaker block here
and
Price respected this breaker block here then came back here and filled in
This tiny little fairly gap here, right if you can see it
And we also took out this so that was continuation at around eight. So remember I said mostly the continations
Purges happened during from eight to ten thirty, right?
So we have a continuation purge right here and the abcd remember
I mean, it's not necessary to get the abcd. You just want to see a purge on the liquidity, right?
and
That's actually pretty much it. You can see we came into the breaker block and then we had our take profit level hit
so
um
Very simple guys. You just have to identify the consolidation phases and you will be good
Okay, and you will you can easily pass your charge with one trade if you get a proper setup
So let's move on to the next example